bueno no los elementos que se va a
tratar en los primeros puntos es
justamente temas de permitir la entrada
de ayuda humanitaria y que puedan de
alguna forma paliar las condiciones de
vida ya está hablado del tema de las
vacunas que era uno de los temas
dramáticos este tema de entradas de las
vacunas en este momento en venezuela y
probablemente uno de los temas que
justamente lleva el régimen a la misa
por los tiempos que pone son las
elecciones regionales al hablar de las
reacciones regionales también logra
quitar de la mesa o al menos aplazar en
la discusión las posibles elecciones
presidenciales con las condiciones
digamos que permanezca ayudarían a
maduro permanecer en el poder